У хасидському кварталі Умані починається свято.
До юдейського Нового року - Рош га-Шана - ще кілька днів, але до міста попри війну вже прибули тисячі паломників.
Кожен хасид хоча б раз у житті має відвідати ось це місце - могилу цадика, тобто праведника Рабі Нахмана.
Більшість часу віряни моляться, сподіваючись на прощення гріхів.
А ще танцюють і співають, як заповідав Рабі Нахман.
Він говорив, що треба радіти, спілкуючись з Богом.
Заповіді цадика для хасидів – священні і непорушні, навіть у часи війни.
Я їхав, тому що Рабі Нахман сказав. Війна-не війна - це однаково.
Я приїхав до цадика Рабі Нахмана, до Умані, святкувати Рош га-Шана.
І я сподіваюся, що в Умані все пройде добре і проблем не буде. І завжди буде тільки мир.
Бажаємо Україні миру, щоб більше не було війни, щоб весь світ жив у мирі,
а Україна знову повернулася до нормального життя.
Цьогоріч над входом до могили цадика - заклик молитися за Україну.
За радянської влади це місце було під приватною забудовою, а паломництво хасидів заборонялося.
Тож до Росії як спадкоємиці СРСР віряни традиційно ставляться негативно.
Путін - терорист.
Зеленський - вері-вері гуд.
Слава Україні!
Зазвичай у хасидському кварталі жінки - небажані.
Вважається, що вони відволікають чоловіків від молитви.
Але цьогоріч на вулицях можна зустріти й хасидок.
Чимало паломників їхали за кілька тижнів до свята, бо побоювалися, що Україна закриє кордони.
А щоб не розлучатися з родиною, брали з собою дружин і дітей.
Так і Нахман з Єрусалима приїхав з усією сім'єю.
Міріам, Сара, Натан, Хая, Нафталія, Паз.
Ми молимося, їмо, купуємо деякі речі. А в основному молимося й молимося.
Ми не боїмося. Чому нам не страшно? Ми приїхали до Рабі, Рабі нас захищає. Люди іноді вмирають.
Але вони не обирають, коли їм померти, Бог обирає.
Поліція і місцева влада цьогоріч не розголошують кількості паломників.
Орієнтовно прибудуть до 10 тисяч людей - утричі менше, ніж торік.
На час святкування запровадили додаткові обмеження.
Від 19 і по 30 вересня діє заборона на продаж алкогольних і слабоалкогольних напоїв,
також продаж піротехнічних виробів, предметів, схожих на зброю.
Також обмежили рух паркування в районі паломництва.
Усі, хто прибувають, проходять ретельну перевірку.
Хаім - хасид, який уже десять років живе в Умані.
Вчу українську мову, добре розумію, говорю трохи, небагато.
Хаім - власник крамниці і готелю навпроти.
З початку війни його бізнес простоював.
Чоловік розповідає, що у своєму готелі безкоштовно поселяв українських військових.
А автомобіль швидкої допомоги, який придбав для єврейської громади, передав ЗСУ.
Нині в готелі Хаіма усі номери заброньовані.
Хасиди дуже пов'язані з Україною, тому що хасидизм починався в Україні.
Наші корені звідси, і ми відчуваємо себе дуже близькими до цієї землі. І ніхто не забере нас звідси.
Війна, не війна - ми завжди сюди прийдемо.
Надворі, у центрі хасидського кварталу, чекає на орендарів підприємець Станіслав.
Він - власник апартаментів просто навпроти могили цадика Нахмана.
Кімната в цьому будинку на один тиждень коштує півтори тисячі доларів.
Підприємець певен, що паломників більше лякав ковід, ніж війна,
тож цьогоріч сподівається на непоганий прибуток.
Можна по-різному ставитися, але я бачу більше плюсів, ніж мінусів.
Так як реально країна зараз під час війни не отримує кошти, ми не виробляємо нічого.
З іншого світу привозять люди гроші, витрачають їх, і місцеві жителі намагаються щось заробити.
І бабусі, які здають тут квартири, можуть по пів року без пенсії жити.
Водночас підприємець визнає: українцям складно конкурувати з хасидами, які викуповують житло в цьому кварталі.
Паломники більш охоче селяться в одновірців.
До того ж хасиди часто привозять з собою навіть продукти, а в Умані витрачають не так багато коштів.
Заступник міського голови Умані Олег Ганіч додає, що місто на організацію паломництва витрачає більше, ніж заробляє.
Не допомагає навіть туристичний збір, який з цього року можна сплатити онлайн.
До сьогоднішнього дня за цим посиланням сплатили тільки сім людей цей туристичний збір.
Тобто якщо місто орієнтовно на 10 тисяч паломників несе затратну частину порядку мільйона гривень -
на прибирання вулиць, на вивіз сміття і так далі, то на сьогодні сплачено тільки сім людей.
По 1300 гривень це виходить 10 тисяч гривень, грубо кажучи.
Більшість уманчан до щорічного паломництва звикли.
Але до приїзду хасидів під час війни ставляться по-різному.
Вони ризикують своїм здоров'ям і напружують нашу обстановку.
І не варто їм було б цьогоріч приїжджати.
Як на мене, ми від цього нікуди не дінемося, це їхня релігія, і ми не обирали цього.
Якщо вони вважають, що вони відчайдухи і можуть в країну воюючу приїхати, не бояться, то це їхній вибір.
Вікторія і Наталя - переселенки з Миколаєва.
Після постійних обстрілів вдома вони вважають Умань безпечним містом і для себе, і для приїжджих вірян.
Ну, якщо їм дозволила наша влада сюди приїхати…
Вони там у своєму кварталі, то хай собі… Це їхнє свято. Ми нормально до цього ставимося.
І Ізраїль, і офіційний Київ радили паломникам цьогоріч утриматися від поїздки в Україну.
Адже гарантувати безпеку від російських ракет не може ніхто.
І все ж у цій синагозі готуються до одночасної молитви кількох тисяч людей на свято Рош га-Шана.
Тут облаштовані укриття в підвалах, де розташовані мікви, тобто бані.
Синагогою опікується Благодійний фонд імені Рабі Нахмана.
Керівник фонду Натан Бен Нун не згоден із рекомендаціями не їхати до Умані, бо вважає місто безпечним.
24 лютого він сам був в Ізраїлі, але в березні повернувся в Україну.
Люди приїжджають і бачать мирну вулицю. Звісно, йде війна. Але всі дотримуються правил. А життя має тривати.
Ізраїль з 1948 у стані війни, але ми живемо. Чому ж не приїжджати?
Ізраїль не закриває кордонів, усі приїжджають і виїжджають.
Надвечір на колишній вулиці Пушкіна, а віднедавна - Туристичній - більш людно.
Паломники ходять до безкоштовних їдалень, спілкуються, купують книжки, грають у футбол.
Невдовзі почнеться комендантська година.
За словами правоохоронців, у цей час вулиці порожніють -
маленький "український Ізраїль" дотримується правил воєнного часу.